cette sculpture est l'oeuvre de Henri
maillot un artiste réunionnais très
connu elle a été réalisée en 2006 cette
situe l'arbre baigneuse c'est une œuvre
en bois et en bronze le socle est en
boîte tamarin
sa forme conique rappelle c'est
quasiment la signature de l'artiste le
cône de l'île de la Réunion
et la partie supérieure est en bronze le
ramage se termine par des corps de femme
pulpeuses légères elles sont en liberté
complètement épanouies il est vrai que
paraissait normal que
l'auteur Cézanne l'auteur des baigneuses
forme géométrisées et inspirer un
sculpteur
les baigneuses sont un thème récurrent
dans l'oeuvre de Henri maillot il a
réalisé pour le musée atelier de Cézanne
les réac pérégation des baigneuses
il a ensuite réalisé aussi une oeuvre
très connue la venue solide au livre qui
est une baigneuse c'est un trophée de
jeu télévisé
les baigneuses ont pris des formes plus
monumentales comme à la fontaine des
salades à Salazie qui est fontaine en
bronze
d'autres baigneuses
monumentsales ont été également exposé
au pavillon français de l'Exposition
universelle à Shanghai en 2010 et depuis
Henri maillot travaille à la Réunion apk
et à Paris
Aix-en-Provence il est toujours en
contact avec cette ville ville de sésame
et on peut dire que cette oeuvre
concentre en elle ces deux passions la
Réunion et sésame
ce poids est un guatemalin de la Réunion
il se prononce a été réalisé ici même à
la Réunion dans la fonderie de Monsieur
Guérin à la Plaine des caves Henri
maillot est un artiste que l'artothèque
est fier de soutenir et qui est présent
bien sûr dans ses collections comme la
probénieuse